so I'm gonna start this off with a
question that I asked you guys in the
last episode now I asked you which
youtuber here on YouTube would you like
me to make a fake Photoshop baby with I
got a ton of responses but here's a few
that I picked now it's your job to tell
me which youtuber is butch Brodie Daly
good question David Robinson wants to
know if I'm gonna be going to VidCon yes
I will be at VidCon and if you join with
VidCon is it's a huge conference with a
ton of youtubers if you're not going you
should probably try to go dangles three
where am I going on vacation next I will
probably be going on my Price is Right
trip to Mexico
driven J wants to know what my favorite
video game is hold on let me go get it
this is my current favorite video game
just dance for Wii it's pretty fun it
only has like 30 songs but let me tell
you I'm a professional Just Answer so
I'm extremely excited about these video
responses this first video these two
girls went out and made signs honk if
you watch iJustine and sorry it's really
really funny check out a quick clip of
the video each answer one of your
questions my most played song on iTunes
is sadly enough my total fail song and
the title of my last video was sexy
stash because I did this this guy right
here his stash is so much sexier than
mine hello this is Andrew gallo
I was wondering if you thought my
mustache was next
thumbs up if I had more than two thumbs
you would get them Facebook questioned
Hershel wants to know if I had all the
money in the world of what would I do
with it I would probably buy the
unlimited supply
so ariel doesn't actually have a
question but they wanted me to tell
their parents to buy them a mac so
parents buy your child mac it will
change their life Victoria wants me to
do a headstand now you guys all know
that I shoot my videos wearing
sweatpants Twitter question Ming wants
to know that I forgot a speeding ticket
I actually have never got a speeding
ticket but let me tell you how many
parking tickets I've gotten a lot
Kristen wants to know if she opened on
my frigerator what would she smell let's
take a look
hello welcome to my refrigerator that's
French
eggs this pizza right here I can promise
you this is probably good enough for
like actually probably longer than a
month a long time Pizza that's probably
what she'd smell hopefully could I found
a receipt if Victoria sent me ten
million cupcakes what would I do with
them I would probably swim in them and
eat them at the same time all right guys
thanks so much for watching this episode
of ask IJ I really love doing these I
love reading all of your comments and
getting all of your video responses and
now my question for you what's your
favorite hat this is mine I just bought
this in the airport I was it was the
Chicago Airport got a little stand there
and they had a little pig and I saw this
one and this was my by choice so yeah
make a video response of your favorite
hat and if you have a cooler hat than me
I just might put you in next week's
episode
by